we've got another alert for you now yes
we're standing by for new cdc guidance
on masks
and early reports suggest that some
vaccinated people will be asked to put
masks on again
in certain circumstances oh this says
the delta variant spreads many areas are
not waiting for official word from the
bible administration st
louis las vegas los angeles county those
are just a few of the places that are
already telling people they have to put
the mask back on
and now several school systems around
the country are doing the same
we've got fox team coverage for you this
afternoon dr mark siegel is standing by
with more
but first to jonathan sarri he is in
atlanta
home of of course the cdc
where we anticipate an update that
should be coming top of the three
o'clock eastern time
hour hi jonathan hi there sandra and
john
federal officials with knowledge tell
fox news that
the cdc is expected to announce today
that it will recommend that even
fully vaccinated individuals continue
wearing masks in
indoor public settings in communities
where there is widespread transmission
there are essentially two things going
on here first of all the delta
variant is spreading rapidly among the
unvaccine
unvaccinated and secondly even though
vaccines
offer a high level of protection
breakthrough infections can still occur
which is why many fully vaccinated
health experts
have been masking up when they walk into
the grocery store take a listen
and i would do that in any group setting
where i
to go to a house of worship go to a
wedding a funeral
any kind of group activity where there
are
people whom i'm not sure all were
vaccinated
the cdc is also expected to recommend
everyone wear masks in schools
several major school districts including
atlanta public schools
have already announced all students and
staff will have to wear masks in the
fall
regardless of whether they've been
vaccinated even though children are at
lower risk for serious illness
atlanta school officials say they're
concerned that the delta variant
may be more than three times more
transmissible than the original virus
they point out that
children under 12 are still ineligible
for the vaccine
and among atlanta public school students
only 18 percent
of those students are fully vaccinated
and 58 percent
of aps employees say that they have
either been vaccinated
or planned to get vaccinated levels not
high enough
to instill confidence among school
officials sandra and john back to you it
will
it will affect all of us to some degree
that updated guidance coming up
shortly jonathan sarri thank you john
sander thanks for more let's bring in dr
mark siegel now and doc we've heard from
the cdc again and again and again for
the last uh
more than a month that people who are
vaccinated do not spread the virus they
don't really contract the virus to any
great degree they don't need to wear
masks
suddenly a reversal on that at least in
certain circumstances
is this new guidance following the
science
well some of the science isn't in yet
john good afternoon
but i think what this is is a reaction
to the delta variant and what jonathan
sarri just said
is part of it which is it's at least two
to three times more transmissible
than the original virus was and studies
have shown that you're more likely to
carry it in your nose much more likely
so even if you're vaccinated let me be
clear
your chances of spreading it if you're
vaccinated is extremely low
compared to if you're unvaccinated your
chances of being hospitalized
if you're vaccinated even against the
delta variant is
really low it's one or two three percent
maximum
the crop the problem they're looking at
now is if you're vaccinated
could you carry it and spread it
unwillingly to someone that's at high
risk someone who's immunocompromised
someone who can't really be protected
that's what they're looking at with
schools they're ahead of the science you
said follow the science they're ahead of
you know why
because studies at schools have shown
that children are
less than one percent likely to spread
it to another child if they have it
but again that's an advance of the delta
variant so
the delta variant changes the playing
field because it's so much more
contagious
and that's why they're reacting this way
parents for sure are going to
fight back and and protest this and it's
only a recommendation it's not a mandate
but again local municipalities can
follow it any way they want
the goal here is to protect people who
can't be fully immunized
yeah you know recommendations from the
cdc at the local level can very quickly
become mandates
as local leaders whether it be school
systems state governors or local
municipalities
look and say well this is what the cdc
says we should be doing
and so we should go ahead and do it um
i wanted to ask you about something else
here too because this is very
important an opinion from the office of
legal counsel
at the department of justice says that
vaccine
mandates are legal and that's to include
government workers private businesses
schools and other entities
legal despite the fact that these
vaccines have only been approved for
emergency use
and don't yet have full fda
authorization
what could that mean for the future well
i see problems with that just as i see
problems with mask mandates rather by
the way because masks again don't work
100
for sure in terms of vaccines the
problem are that there's no flexibility
when you start with the word mandates
what about people who got over covet
and they're protected on that basis what
about people who had one shot
plus covid but they don't have the
official two shots what about people
that ask for exemptions
if the whole pool asks for exemptions
how effective is that mandate
so there are real concerns about about
superimposing mandates
one thing for sure everybody in this
country needs this vaccine the vaccine
is incredibly effective
it's the only way to fight the delta
variant but the real question is
how to get there and the mandates may
very well backfire
you know it i can imagine that if
businesses and
governments uh in schools etc started
requiring people to get a vaccine before
they came back to work that that could
potentially increase
the number of people who are in the
vaccinated pool but do you think it
could also cause blowback
yeah it's gonna cause blowback that's
why i think
that we have to talk to people you know
we're seeing some uptick
in vaccine compliance now because of the
delta variant we need to
communicate to people what are you
afraid of i'm more afraid of covid than
i am of this vaccine
you know when they start seeing more big
government the same day
mandate you know masks vaccines
everything seems like it's being
pushed on to people i think people want
to feel like they make a decision
themselves the right decision here is
the vaccine
extremely important and by the way
health care workers have to comply with
my point here
we don't even have 100 percent of health
care workers vaccinated that's an
absolute disgrace
physicians have to and nurses all have
to take the vaccine
and be out there as role models yeah
about a month ago
uh in terms of covet new cases they're
about fifteen thousand
every day now that number is up uh on a
couple of days
to some ninety thousand i know the
governor kay ivey of alabama is very
upset about the low level of
immunization against covet in her state
it stands about 34.1 percent
but has there not been mixed messaging
from joe biden during the campaign and
now the white house
in terms of a vaccination i remember
kamala harris
who was then the vice presidential
running mate candidate saying that she
wouldn't take the trump vaccine
i think that caused an initial backlash
among republicans i think now
the problem is that it's still coming
across as partisan
i feel that the administration should
flat out say we got this vaccine as a
tremendous tool from the previous
administration
we're running with it that would help to
bring bring on board more conservatives
you know without again the partisan
divide here
or the scolding or the bullying when you
say the word unity
you should mean we're meeting you where
you live not we're superimposing where
we live
and that's the credit is all there for
the pre for the trump administration in
terms of
getting this vaccine out there and
getting it to market and getting it
distributed
yeah unfortunately politics uh still
very much at play when it comes to this
disease dr mark siegel as always
thanks for the information we appreciate
it hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now